getting so
worn out from all of these time screens
or at least the one time scramble
what should i do okay let's try the
let's try the scandinavian
this is a really dumb line though what
does he exchange queens
doesn't he know that i'm supposed to be
the greatest endgame player of all time
uh that was supposed to be um
i don't know i guess it's funny because
it's true
right
i'm not not that high on myself
i am but i usually don't admit it
publicly
anyway this is this is a queenless
middle game not
a uh an endgame yet so
and there are a lot of tactics let's say
if he had gone
if he had gone bishop c6 there it could
have been very interesting
bishop c6 bishop c6 knight e5 bishop g2
rook g1 bishop h3 um
knight b5 and uh who knows what's going
on
um now i have a comfortable position
don't think i'm better but
it's always uh always nice to
to be the side that's that's pushing
with with black
maybe this was a bit too ambitious
but
then again why not
he's played pretty passively so far so
there's no reason why he should uh
he should feel the uh the urgency yet
um yeah this 94 move i'm
kind of happy to see
since
yeah bishop c5 is not going to happen
because of bishop b4
and with the knight always being
a bit unstable on e4
d4 is nothing no it's not an issue
yeah knight c5 that's a good move
suppose i have to take it
should i go [ __ ] past three or should i
not
i will go 986 if he wants to go knight
e1
that's fine by me that knight is it's
not gonna have any prospects
for a while i'm gonna go knight f5 then
push h4
h5h4 and i'll be very comfortable
maybe you can go knight d2
that i didn't consider
bishop chief two rook g1
no tactics yeah
good move shouldn't have allowed that
so should no he's he's quite fine
very slightly better but it's mostly
mostly a theory rather than
them practical edge because
yeah in practice it should be should be
fairly rare
i will still win the game though seeing
as
i am as earlier noted the greatest
endgame player of all time according to
some
uh but it's not gonna be easy
a5 feels feels useful
not to have that that one getting
getting fixed s3 f3 is good
he's making all the right moves he's
clearly a very
very solid positional player now he
probably should go
king d2 hinting at uh
after one and
i don't know what i was saying earlier i
don't have an edge
position is just equal that was a poor
move though
now we do have some pressure
already threatening bgp4 and
g4 than knight h4
and the f3 sighing and
he's gonna lose a pawn
i will catch one but that's still
a fairly healthy extra point
that is a good move actually
i'm not sure he realizes the point but
um
that's a good move i'll try and be
tricky and go
rg8 first
i'm threatening bishop b4 followed by
not g5 so he should go
bridge b3 after which i should take on
an e4 anyways but i don't know
by by delaying it i was trying to
to do something
not quite sure what
oh i'm allowing bishop h6
but i have king e6 and then if rook g7
i have um yeah brook h8
that doesn't work maybe it does i don't
know
yeah the only worrying thing is 15 e6
he may have c3
my knight is getting dangerously short
of
shoulder space so i guess i should bring
it back but
this wasn't very smooth technique
that's for sure
what am i doing nobody ever taught me to
put the to work behind the pass pawn
let's go
and now time has run out but the
position
is also hopeless so
okay